[Applause]
foreign
you're getting better all right okay
good job good job you guys you guys can
stay you can stay all right so today is
9 11 which means that CNN and MSNBC it's
Monday
because 911 is that little thing that
paled in comparison to January 6th right
now for those of you under 30 It's
probably hard for you to appreciate what
a jolt that day was to the country not
since Pearl Harbor had we taken such a
hit on the home front here in New York
we were all walking around watching the
skies usually we look at the ground so
we don't step on needles poop or a
passed out Brian kilmead
but 22 years ago
years ago what would come next but you
knew the threat was out there it was a
different time the country pulled
together in our federal agencies
actually worked together against al
Qaeda instead of surveilling parents who
complained that their kids gym teacher
wears a bra and a jock strap
but those people were by almost any
metric successful the high point came
when Osama Bin Laden got a taste of
old-time American frontier justice as
Rob O'Neill used automatic weapons to
ventilate his turban yipikay douchebag
you're not dealing with the French here
[Applause]
version of the threat the terrorists
that Obama called junior varsity maybe
because they're the only dudes he could
beat at bowling
came after that Donald Trump for those
with a memory longer than a week before
Trump came along we were told by the
so-called experts that Isis was an idea
a destructive ideology that couldn't be
killed much like communism or recycling
yeah that felt good
so let me ask you when was the last time
you heard anything about Isis
exactly Carrot Top gets more pressed and
he hasn't killed anybody
lately
thanks to Trump's willingness to take
the gloves off and deal with Isis in the
only language they understand raw
Firepower Isis was no longer the cool
kid on the terrorist block the beheaders
were beheaded but as isis's Allure and
threat faded a different threat emerged
yep the one that attacks from within
like a burrito
now it's from the very government who
decided terrorism was in the rear view
mirror
so instead we got Crossfire hurricane
with our national security apparatus
turning its Firepower on a duly elected
president
now you know these people you know their
names 51 of them signed a letter telling
us Hunter's laptop was Russian was a
Russian operation if you don't know who
I'm talking about just Google
politicians who got gigs at CNN
four of them had been heads of the CIA I
wonder if any of them ever sent money to
a Nigerian prince
and because the media cheerleads them
there's no introspection there's no
hesitation the Demps just keep coming
but not at the terrorists or the drug
cartels they're not targeting a Taliban
resurrecting itself after the shambolic
pull out from Afghanistan a pull out
that gave those goat humpers a happier
ending ending than a Midtown Massage
parlor
[Applause]
Yep they're actually coming at you and
me to them School children's parents or
the equivalent of the al-shabab Brigade
today the Dems believe that the
Constitution's Bill of Rights was some
silly top 10 list tweeted out by
BuzzFeed you know 10 signs that your cat
is a wizard
but the First Amendment fascism a recent
decision from the federal fifth Circuit
Court of Appeals found that the White
House CDC Surgeon General and FBI had
engaged in activities that coerced
social media companies into suppressing
a broad range of protected political
speech in other words how dare you
question mask and vaccine mandates on
social media you insurrectionist I'm not
sure who's a worse doctor Dr fauci or Dr
Jill
I'd rather get a prostate exam from Dr
Ruth
very soft hands
fit a lot up there no the Second
Amendment optional New Mexico's Governor
has decided it doesn't apply in her
jurisdiction I didn't realize it works
this way and it's great I just decided
that I don't need to pay taxes or or
obey traffic lights and only a sucker
would obey those laws against public
nudity man Larry Kudlow who had the
right idea all along
how about the basic right for
self-determination for you and your
family in California a new bill was just
passed that requires parents to take a
position on their child's gender in
custody cases what's that Mr Smith you
refuse to call your son Billy by his new
name Brittany well say goodbye to your
son now judges can simply award the kid
to whichever parent goes along with
childhood self-mutilation mutilation
that the poor kid believes is necessary
to get the approval of places like the
view who would want to transition to a
woman after seeing that crew
unless unless you want to transition to
a Men's prison football team
but that's how we determine custody now
following a sick fad with as much
scientific evidence as leg warmers if
leg warmers made you cut your kids feet
off now please don't make me go through
all the other amendments that guy Trace
McGillicuddy or whatever his name is has
to come on after us
but as we close out another 911 remember
what occurred that day and recall that
the real threats to this country used to
remain from outside and not from within
you know before our brain dead president
and his minion of marxist maggots took
the helm we need to wake up to the fact
that Biden and the progressives continue
to focus their Firepower not externally
but on all of us you don't believe me
well as Joe returns from the G20 with a
pile of policy initiatives telling us
what horrible polluting people we are
who will also be the first president not
to attend one of the 911 site memorials
maybe because the real threat to Biden
isn't Terror it's any working microphone
remember the famous song You Know Good
morning Vietnam well good evening
Vietnam the Indian looks at John Wayne
and points to the union so says he's a
lion dog face pony soldier but I don't
know about you but I'm going to go to
bed the third world the excuse me third
world the uh the the
southern hemisphere had access to change
it had access we it wasn't
confrontational at all thank you
everybody press conference thanks
everyone
thank you
[Laughter]
it's like an extra long Oscar speech
but you know it must be tough minding
the store when you don't have much of a
mind left
[Applause]
South Carolina Congresswoman Nancy Mays
he lives every day like it's laundry day
founder of the loftusparty.com Michael
Loftus
as a former gymnast she preps for every
broadcast by chalking up I'll kick host
Charlie Arnold
[Applause]
he's so strong he could lift a car to
save people he doesn't like New York
Times best-selling author comedian and
former
congresswoman thank you for coming on
the show I appreciate it we're big fans
of you
likewise my mom's a big fan it's always
the Mom it's never the hot daughter your
mom loves Tyler maybe she has a hot mom
yes she is how old's your mother she's
80. well just turn Iris that's it's
tired of birthday she turned 81 last
week wow yeah I bet she's very very
attractive elegant and uh sophisticated
she's stunning and loves Tyrus
Pirates share some no all the all the
blue hairs are mine
[Laughter]
a trend uh here going on with the what
would you see what's going on in New
Mexico you see the speech stuff you see
the private property somehow just
disappearing and no one cares yeah we're
entering a constitutional crisis
essentially and when you watch the press
conference in Hanoi from yesterday I
mean it's only a matter of time until we
have President Kamala right I mean it's
just it's very scary look weak on the
world stage it's not good for America
yeah what do you what do you make of
this whole thing with the Second
Amendment stuff is that well we're also
we're seeing even Democrats condemn do
you think it's a trial balloon I don't
know if it's a trial Bloom but I
definitely know that we are breaching
this crisis with the Constitution what
does it mean she should be obviously be
impeached yes but Democrats are even
condemning this you just can't erase the
Constitution I mean that's not how this
works we should murder her with the Bill
of Rights
it's a great idea yeah exactly you know
Michael as a lesbian homeless person
has the government also been targeting
your freedoms and your rights they they
don't stop and and please give
generously for just fifteen dollars a
day you can save a homeless lesbian
I will be there okay
I like how uh like the the government is
actively censoring people on on Facebook
just like trampling First Amendment
rights and and everybody's like ah what
are you gonna do they do that now uh
this is insane and and someone needs to
go to jail it's like we've become numb
to this stuff yeah ever since like the
Patriot Act and the fisa courts but like
there's these these huge like nuclear
lies that America's just like oh well
what are you gonna do that's how they
are now it's like we're now living in in
Misery the the movie Misery and and and
the intelligence agency is Kathy Bates
and she just comes in and hobbles us
every morning and we're like oh well
that's what they do they frame people is
it misery or is it Beavis and Butthead I
can't I get confused it's a hard time
figuring out which one's butt head right
you know you know the uh I think the
just Tech social media has got us so
filled up that we're letting these
rights go because we're too busy
checking Instagram and whatnot do you
think it's it's not Joe's fault he's
gone right Charlie I mean he's like he
he really is like the uh the principal
of South Park at this point I
as far as Joe is concerned that I think
that might have been his best
performance yet I'm not sure yeah uh but
he just had from from beginning to end
it was just filled with so many Delights
I mean the fact that he told us all he
was going to bed I mean it looked like
he was exhausted up there yes all of the
talking he had to do he had to correct
the reporter don't forget because she
said a word wrong because Joe never says
anything wrong right he made all those
weird jokes uh just everything from top
to bottom was very strange I hate weird
jokes
really you know what the thing that's
scary and you you mentioned this Nancy
is that Kamala could be next right she's
do you know there's rumors now that the
candidate for the Democrats isn't isn't
going to be Kamala it's going to be
Michelle Obama no really yeah that's
been going around forever and the thing
is I just think
um Barack is I don't know he's gay ning
some wisdom
um I mean he I mean yeah Obama Brock
loves men chinning his wife but I don't
think she wants politics
I I I you look so terrified I don't know
what I don't know what I can say you're
back from that how do you how do you
come out back from that I mean there's
there's a lot of things that go on in
that family that I am very unsure about
I just saw some pictures also of the
daughters running around this smoking
smoking and yeah like in like the weird
clothing I'm like what is going on here
this is just not what you'd expect from
the family of a former president but
listen you know what I don't make the
rules here no you don't I don't make any
of them no I make the rules Here Charlie
don't forget that
all right thank you they're applauding
the fact that I'm a dictator
um see that's where we are
when will America say that's enough
Tyrus oh they're not speaking our
language so it doesn't really matter
here's how cold they are to President
Biden they let him bring out a
microphone to do a speech they had two
microphones waiting for him that's
I have my own
if it was a fight it went two rounds too
long as soon as he said hello it should
have been thank you good night God bless
thanks for coming out I should have
thrown a white towel on when he said my
favorite song Good morning Vietnam
it's a movie
and that wasn't the point that's just
what the radio guys said yes and then he
said you know now it's good evening
Vietnam and that's when this should have
ended that was by his best out he's gone
you know what the also they did they
didn't have his giant telemarket uh
teleprompters it's on both sides because
you know usually when he talks he does
this um
he had nothing to read so and he had his
cars but he didn't have his bifocals on
or eight vocals probably
so he's they're done with him they're
done with him and it is misery but you
have it wrong
Kamala is the woman from misery and
she's torturing him
let me let me lay the facts down that
weird cackle you see misery oh you dirty
bird that sounds very common
weird one
Day Mad the next day
he's getting worse she's probably
putting a little something in that you
know soup in the morning so no I'm your
misery man
let's go on the school bus so
all that aside
that woman who did that made that thing
about the Constitution is
the impeachment should have been
yesterday but again this is all our
fault start looking at who you're voting
for quit voting for somebody
you make Equity votes I don't want to
hear you complain amen we just saw that
where it was in California where they
all got together and they needed to they
wanted the whole city council of Muslim
Americans in the office and guess what
they didn't support ulterior lifestyle
and they were like how could they do
this did you bother to meet who you were
voting yeah because of their religious
beliefs might influence the way they
think stop making Equity votes all right
we gotta move on hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else